let's say we have some type of hard flat
frictionless surface right over here
that's my drawing of a hard flat
frictionless surface and on that i have
a block and that block is not
accelerating in any direction it is just
sitting there and let's say we know the
weight of that block it is a 10 newton
block
so my question to you is pause this
video and think about what are all of
the forces that are acting on this block
all right now let's work through this
together and to do it i'm going to draw
what's known as a free body
diagram to think about all of the forces
and the reason why it's called a free
body diagram is that we just focus on
this one body and we don't draw
everything else around it and we just
draw the forces acting on it and there's
actually two typical ways of drawing a
free body diagram i'll do them both so
first i could draw it this way so this
is my block here
now i told you that it weighs 10 newtons
the weight of an object that's the force
of gravity acting on that object and it
would be downwards so we have from this
10 newtons right over here we know that
there is a downward force
the force of gravity acting on the mass
of this object of
10 newtons it has a magnitude of 10
newtons and the force is acting
downwards we could say this is the
magnitude of the force of gravity
and when you draw a free body diagram
it's typical to show your vectors
originating out of the center of that of
that object in your drawing now my
question to you is is that the only
force acting on this if you think it is
what would happen to the object well it
would start or would be accelerating
downwards but i just said that this is
not accelerating in any direction so
there must be something that counteracts
this and there is there's the normal
force of this surface acting on the
block that surface is what's keeping the
block from accelerating downwards and i
will do that with this vector right over
here so it's going to be going upwards
and it's going to have the exact same
magnitude just in the opposite direction
so i could say the magnitude of the
normal force the normal force's
magnitude right over here is also going
to be equal to 10 units but it's going
upwards and we can see that these two
are going to net out and so you have no
net force acting in this vertical
dimension and i have no forces i haven't
thought about any or drawn any in the
horizontal direction and so that's why
you have no net force in total and this
thing isn't going to be accelerating
now i mentioned that there's other ways
to draw a free body diagram another way
that you might see it is like this where
you see the body
and from the outside of the body you see
the vectors being drawn so in this
situation you would have 10 newtons
downward
and you would have 10 newtons upward
this is another way that you might see
free body diagram free body diagrams
drawn
now what i want to do is do something
interesting to this block let me redraw
it
so i have my surface here
my hard frictionless surface
and it's flat and i still have my block
here
it's my 10 newton block but now i'm
going to apply a force to it
i am going to apply
a force
like that is in this direction
it's in this direction and its magnitude
let's say its magnitude is 20 newtons
and just so that we know the direction
this angle right over here let's say
that that is
60 degrees i'll say theta is equal to 60
degrees the magnitude
of this force is equal to
20 newtons so what would the free body
diagram now look like
well it might be tempting to just draw
the force right on one of these free
body diagrams something like that
something like that and that would not
be
inaccurate but we would have to watch
out because this force is acting at an
angle so if we were to break it up into
its horizontal and vertical components
some part of that force is acting
downward and so you're actually going to
have a larger normal force to counteract
that and some other component is going
to be working horizontally and so what
we want to do is actually break things
up because if you leave it at this angle
it gets very very confusing so what i
want to do is i want to break up this
new blue force into its horizontal and
vertical components and to do so we just
have to remember a little bit of our
basic trigonometry
if i have a force like this
if i have a force like this
and it is acting at an angle
theta right over here with the
horizontal and i want to break it up
into its horizontal
and its vertical components
and its vertical components
if the magnitude of the hypotenuse is
capital f
then the magnitude of the adjacent side
to this angle this comes straight out of
socatoa from our right triangle
trigonometry it would be the magnitude
of our hypotenuse times the cosine
of this angle
and the magnitude of the vertical
component that would be the magnitude of
our hypotenuse times the sine
of that angle and you could think about
it the other way as well
if the force was like this
where it's just going in the opposite
direction but once again you have this
angle theta
and now the components would look like
this where the vertical component would
have the same magnitude but now it would
be pointing downwards and the horizontal
component would have the same magnitude
but now it is pointing to the left
it is the same idea if this force has
magnitude f that's represented by the
hypotenuse of this triangle
then the magnitude of our horizontal
component is still going to be
f cosine theta the vector's not going in
the other direction and the magnitude of
our vertical component here
is going to be
f
sine
theta
and so what about this scenario over
here
well in this scenario our vertical
component is going to look like this
and our horizontal component is going to
look like this and so what's the
magnitude of our horizontal component
well it's going to be the magnitude of
our hypotenuse times the cosine of the
60 degrees so this is going to be
20 newtons times the cosine of 60
degrees and it's really helpful in both
trigonometry and physics classes to know
the values of your sines your cosines
and your tangents at angles like 0
degrees 30 degrees 60 degrees 90 degrees
45 degrees you could use a calculator
here but it's useful to know that the
cosine of 60 degrees is one-half so 20
times one-half this is going to be equal
to
10
newtons and if we want to know the
magnitude of our vertical component
well this is going to be 20 newtons
times the sine
of 60 degrees once again this is useful
to know it is square root of 3 over 2
and so 20 divided by 2 is 10 so this is
going to be 10 square roots of 3
newtons and so we can use that
information we've broken up our original
vector into two component vectors that
if you took their sum you'd get your
original one but what's useful now is
that we've broken it up into vectors
that are parallel or perpendicular to
our surface which will allow us to think
about what nets against these things
that i already have in place
so let me draw that so actually i'll
first draw this type of free body
diagram
so
there is my block
and i have i have the force of gravity
acting on it downwards
i will draw it right over here so that's
10 newtons that is the force of gravity
acting downwards now is that the only
thing that i have acting downwards no i
also have the vertical component of this
applied force and so this is going
downwards 10 squared to 3 newtons
and these aren't drawn perfectly to
scale but hopefully you get the idea so
this is 10 square roots of 3
newtons just like that
and now what is our normal force
assuming that our surface is able to not
be compressed in any way that it is a
hard frictionless surface well now our
normal force is going to counteract both
of these forces our normal force might
look something like this once again i
haven't drawn it completely to scale but
this would be 10
plus 10 square roots of 3
newtons
and what about now in the horizontal
direction
well i have this blue vector
right here and so that is going to the
right
with a magnitude of 10 newtons
10 newtons
and so now you can hopefully appreciate
why a free body diagram is really really
really useful
just looking at this i can predict
what's going to happen to my block i
would say look this upward force is
completely netted out by these downward
forces or these downward forces are
completely netted out by this upward
force
and the only net force that i have is 10
newtons to the right and so that lets me
know that hey since i have a net force
to the right this block is going to
accelerate to the right